this course covers everything you need
to know to create automate and publish
API documentation that your developers
partners and users will love Jason
Harmon developed this course Jason
brings over 20 years of experience in
the technology and API world and he's
the CTO of stoplight hello free code
Camp community and welcome to appek
University and this course on API
documentation best practices my name is
Dan barahona co-founder of appek
University and for the next 90 minutes
or so you'll learn all about API
documentation including how to write
good doc good documentation techniques
and tools for creating documentation and
even the business impact of good
documentation your instructor for the
course is my good friend Jason Harman
CTO of stoplight and one of the most
recognized experts in this field I'd
also like to invite you to check out all
our free courses on appc University
you'll find courses on API pen testing
the oasp API top 10 API security
fundamentals and more all the courses on
our site are free and include quizzes to
assess your knowledge and if you
complete everything and pass the final
quiz we'll issue you a certificate and
badge to recognize your accomplishment
thanks again for watching and I hope you
enjoy this
[Music]
course welcome to the documentation best
practices course we're going to talk
today about creating great docs and as
really almost a byproduct of that why
that's going to improve your security
picture uh but to be clear we're going
to take a big look picture at kind of
documentation in general with a focus on
apis doing that in a lot of companies
this is the lifeblood of how software is
working now quick agenda of what we're
going to cover we'll talk about Who I Am
wrot with just so you maybe believe why
you should listen uh Define what we mean
by API documentation and kind of what
that
entails from a business perspective why
why API documentation can make a really
big impact some techniques and tools and
and finally best practices for what
works well in this
space so first up on our agenda who am I
my name is Jason Harman I'm the chief
technology officer at stoplight and I
oversee all the giggy stuff engineering
product security it I also host a
podcast called apat intersection all of
this is more relevant in thaten a
practitioner of building platforms and
and apis and that sort of thing at
everything ranging from Big public
companies like PayPal and Expedia group
down to fast growing star type form you
should and all of that has comeing into
play in in my role as stoplight and I've
been pretty involved in the community at
large I think I've always been seen as
an advocate for API
documentation so let's define what we
mean what is API documentation I think
documentation is a big nebulous word so
we're going to start start big and Whitt
our way
down in simple terms this is a human
readable description of how developers
will enable machines to communicate with
each other so man of full but this is my
attempt to wrap up a few different
things one is documentations for humans
this is for people to read and
understand the developer aspect that's
not the whole story we're not just
talking about documentation for
developers but at the end of the day the
outcome um why people are engaging with
these sorts of things is for developers
to create connections between machines
that's what apis are all
about now I do think a lot of what we're
going to talk about is portable to many
other Realms of documentation especially
technical documentation and in general
in the world that we live in today
interprocess communication between
machines is quite often what we're doing
so I think it's pretty
relevant so there's a couple of
different high level things that we
would look at when we talk about
documentation at large the first is
documenting your product and this may or
may not entail
apis there's the second big bucket of of
documenting apis and kind of the
difference here is in product
documentation you might be showing
someone how to use a product and quite
often this is going to be a
point-and-click experience kind of thing
where it's how do I go set this up and I
can go figure that out from the
documentation API documentation can be a
bit of a unique creature in that one
it's pretty developer Centric and again
we'll talk about the other personas that
we should consider but it's really about
how to write code to use something
pretty different in nature and this is
really more where we're going to go I
think there's a lot of Concepts that are
applicable to both in here but we're
going to focus on that kind of more
developer Centric
documentation to that question who is
this documentation 4 and as I said
developers mentioned that a number of
times but it's really important when
you're sitting down to write this kind
of content that it's both developers and
a lot of different non-developers my
tagline to help remember this developers
try and business buys what do I mean by
that is that increasingly in in
engineering and it circles leaders are
looking to Developers for is this
something that can use and live with and
with apis this is especially important
you're in essence building a
relationship with another company when
you use their API so you're counting on
the fact that a developer you're going
to have a very narrow window of
attention they're going to go try it out
see how it works and make a judgment
call so that developer experience the
big picture of it is really important
and documentation is the first thing
they're going to see the first thing
they're going to interact with so
critical to capture their imagination
and confidence quickly however at the
end of the day most developers are not
the ones making buying decision and so
there are often technology or Business
Leaders or both who are involved in
approving the budgets to go by these
sorts of things so when we're talking
about content it's important that we
speak in two voices we'll look at
examples of breaking this down and a way
to do it that it is easy enough as a
rule of thumb and speaks to these two
audiences because we really need to
communicate in different
ways there's another kind of Matrix
aspect to this which is are you building
Internal Documentation for within your
organization to bring Folks up to speed
on how to use apis between different
teams and again this could apply to
other things as well or is it externally
focused and this is really productized
potentially monetized thing that you're
going to put out there to the world and
external doesn't always mean publicly
open more and more more we see that
partner programs and this sort of thing
you might invite someone to a portal
where they're going to read the
documentation on how to integrate and
create a long-term
relationship there are definitely some
nuanced differences between these these
different kind of environments in
internal
environments really it's just fair to
say that authorization and access
control patterns are going to look
pretty different for internal apis
versus external and we'll talk talk
plenty more trust me about the things
that we need to pay attention to around
off patterns and why they're so
important but it is important to
recognize that you're going to have a
pretty different look on internal versus
external
facing um additionally for Internal
Documentation you're often going to have
a lot of proprietary information links
to perhaps other knowledge stores on
where to find out more about the
implementation behind this or the team
who's supporting it these sorts of
things you might have operation metrics
that are linked into this to point to
how healthy is this thing should you
trust it based on its track record of
operational Health as we're in the
external world you're often going to put
a lot more effort into customizing The
Experience putting stronger branding
messaging and really some developer
marketing on why should you use this
thing now I do think these external
concerns are starting to creep into the
internal world and a thought of this is
not really the documentation writer's
job per se but again we're trying to
look at a total developer experience
which really entails many aspects so
these are just things to keep in mind if
you're going down the road uh let's go
build a documentation Bo for apis you're
going to have a pretty different
consideration set depending on the
environment that it's being published to
but I will say that I still think that
the developers try business by Mantra
holds up in both okay the basic context
of what is API documentation let's take
a little deeper step into what are the
different types as I said documentation
can be a bit of a nebulous word and we
really need to get a little more precise
as we get into creating something
practical and useful so there's really
three highlevel things that you tend to
see in this type of documentation and
again I think a lot of this is portable
to things outside of apis
the first is reference material and I
think for most say developers when we
think about API documentation this is
the stuff we're thinking about it's
really the Encyclopedia of how to go use
this API when you already know what it
does you understand the ideas and you're
ready to go write code references where
you go however if you only document an
API in its reference format and and
we'll look at what these look like so
don't worry if reference doesn't mean
much to you yet all is more important is
the concepts right what are the things
in simple terms what does this API do
but often it's not just one API it's
that there's a set of ideas of why you
would come use this Suite of apis what
are the big things that you're trying to
accomplish so in sort of product speak
we might say what is the job that you're
trying to do and then furthermore you
might have tasks and this is where could
be a whole other chain of things that
need to be done you might want to
showcase certain steps that users need
to take in order to accomplish so these
are pretty similar and it's a pretty
blurry line between Concepts and tests
but we'll look at some examples what
these things look
like so first up on API reference I just
picked on one API portal here and we'll
look at a few different ones but this is
pager duties and one example of L their
API
is listing escalation policies now what
we're really looking at here is
reference material and you'll notice
that right off the top we've got request
and query parameters on the right we've
got off information there's a request
sample kind of falling off the bottom
there we've got you know the get so the
verb that's being used in HTTP and then
the URL that's being called so there's a
lot of kind of parameterized information
for an engineer is filling in the blanks
that they need on knowing how to call
this thing but you'll notice a couple of
things
first the first paragraph of this
reference material is not really
speaking to developers if I looked and
said what is list escalation policies
mean first list all of the existing
escalation policies so that tells me the
list and I'm getting the existing thing
that's not something that is fabricated
from thin air so it's not a lot but I'm
starting to learn escalation policies
Define which user should be alerted at
which time that's what an escalation
policy is right so now we're starting to
get tidbits of
Concepts and this is I think to that
point of if it's a non-developer who's
browsing pager Duty site and saying is
this something that we should be using
now in this case I'm being contrived
because peder duty is a pretty developer
Centric product as a whole but let's
imagine for a moment that I'm shopping
as a non-technical user I get a sense of
what this thing
does now if this isn't enough this is
typically a very topical description
functional description of what this does
we might dig into what are the concepts
behind this and in this case Pedro Duty
expressly calls out an API Concepts
document right they have a specific
thing for this but let's come back to
the concepts in a moment the other part
that I really want to break down for you
is the anatomy of API reference material
now there are certainly lots of other
things out there we're going to talk
about more of the rest style apis a
request response kind of thing you'll
notice on the far left we've got
responses and across the top we've got
different status codes in kind of a rest
stle API 200 is good 400 the user did
something wrong 500ish errors that
something's wrong in the server we'll
look at that in a later section a little
more in detail but you notice the B
section here for developers this is what
we're looking for right what's the
information that comes back and I need
every field described in an adequate
enough fashion that I know what that
field means so if I looked at this and
let's say offset and limit weren't
described most developers would guess
this is probably
pagination same thing with total and
more these are pretty easy but as we get
into the escalation policies summary in
this case is a pretty specific meaning
it's short form ser generated string
sync important information so it's okay
this isn't really something that someone
hand curated this is a server generated
value this has some kind of insight
built into it so I understand that
there's going to be something
interesting and valuable in that summary
information and as we go if we went down
the list of all these properties there's
things to learn at every step and so
just keep in mind that when you're
looking at the fields were returned in
the body of a response the field name
itself would often have incredible
ambiguity so for instance if I said look
at the summary in escalation policies
what does summary mean summary is a very
ambiguous term it's used in lots and
lots of domains and it needs a precise
definition of what summary means in
order for it to have adequate context to
be useful now we're kind of looking at
it backwards here from left to right
we're looking at the response first but
for what it's worth this is what people
quite often want to see first is before
I do all the work to make a request am I
going to get in the response resp wantse
does this have the data that I need but
if we shift over to that request side
you'll notice right off the bat Security
in this case it's an API key and there's
probably a whole set of steps to go get
that it is an important and critical
first step to making any request is
there some kind of security being passed
here um beyond that is all the query
parameters and you might see headers as
well which I have highlighted on the
right and these are going to depend on
what kind of endpoint or calling whether
it's a get or put or a post or a delete
you're going to see different kind of
interaction patterns here so just keep
in mind that like in this case we're
looking at a list of things and you'll
notice a lot of stuff with like offset
and limit total these are paging
controls and we'll talk about kind of
consistency this is a great example of
the kind of thing that I would expect if
I look across all of PAG your duty
apis that I would tend to see these same
paging parameters and paging response
parameters as a a consistent pattern so
that if I write code as a client against
this API I can reuse how paging works
against the pager data API across many
apis and not have to write a bespoke way
of doing it every time I integrate with
yet another operation in headers I think
this is one that a lot of folks maybe
don't grasp so well and it won't go too
far down the rabbit hole with the API
thing but in this case accept in content
type these are about content negotiation
and this is an important thing to cover
as well in pager Duty's case they're
calling out that they're using a
specific media type that's bespoke to
pager Duty when we look in there we see
this plus Json which tells me it's going
to be Json data they're just telling me
that application D and pager duty is
their specific domain description of
what's going to be in that Jason and
then version two it's another important
one to cover is how are you handling
versioning in pag your Duty's case
they're passing it as part of a media
type in the accept header and making it
an implied part of their content
negotiation content type is again just
part of that content negotiation you'll
see here application Jason it is
increasingly likely that you're only
going to be seeing application Json type
content in apis but always be mindful
that there could be other content types
supported on older stuff you might see
XML in specific domains you could see
very specific media types to that domain
something like VCF for contact
information right so be mindful that
developers may have multiple ways or
multiple formats that they can retrieve
from one API so I promised we dig into
those status codes and this is a concept
that we really need to embrace is that
if the documentation is the first thing
that a developer goes and looks to to
learn how to use an API and they form
their first request it's pretty likely
that their first interaction with that
API is going to produce an error because
they don't know how to use it and maybe
they've made mistakes in how they formed
that request so it's essential that we
describe what happens in the case that
is not 200 and something 200 class
errors are success 400 classes you did
something wrong in 500 classes I did
something wrong if you're the API
Builder so for a client a 400 class
error is going to tell you there's
probably something wrong with the way
that you provided those parameter values
and you need to fix that in order to get
a valid response now the shape of that
error again this is one of those
consistency things I'm going to dog here
we're going to come back to talking
about consistency but if I'm using an
API from pager Duty and I use it one I'm
going to write error handling code and
I'm going to expect that all the other
apis they offer I should be able to
reuse that error handling code by and
large so that's going to save me a lot
of code as a client of it and not having
to duplicate all those efforts from a
documentation perspective one it's
critical that you're focusing a lot of
energy early on in what are the errors
going to look like both in their shape
and in their content so in this case
we're really just showing the shape but
it certainly is common that you might
have some breakdown of what kind of
errors are you're going to get and this
often
Beyond just the status code if we look
on the right in the body you'll see that
underneath that error object that is
returned in the response in the case of
this 400 that there's a message so
you'll see in the example message and
this should tell the human what's wrong
there's quite often a code that's
accompanied with it and this goes a
level deeper than just those HTTP status
codes and goes into an application
specific error code and quite often
having reference material that
enumerates what those error codes mean
will help users when they're not looking
at the documentation down the road and
they're writing code and they suddenly
get a 400 error and some weird code in a
message that they don't understand they
want to be able to go back to the
documentation and find what does this
error mean or detail so another common
practi is in these errors that you would
actually provide a link back to the
documentation I say it's common practice
I I wish it was more common
but it is a a commonly understood
affordance I think more folks should
Implement at the very least in our
documentation we should always have some
place to go look up those error codes
and really just understand in general
what our errors going to look like on
your
platform and for what it's worth bottom
left here I wanted to highlight that
beyond all of that customer facing or
kind of API consumer facing attention
that we should pay to probably their
first interaction with errors the mere
practice of documenting what the errors
on I promise you it's going to surface
weirdness in your error handling and if
you don't go through that that
discipline of documenting those things
those are going to be surprises that no
one is going to welcome this is the
first taste of something we're going to
hit quite a bit is that you're going to
uncover quality problems here and part
of that quality I think is going to be a
security aspect if you have access
control that don't work right and you're
not getting 401 or 403 errors typically
for off related issues where you
expected them even as a writer who's
addressing this you should be able to
flag to the team that look we've got a
hole in our access control that I can't
explain in the documentation so this is
where there's a lot of implicit quality
and security enhancement that goes with
documentation and I think errors is one
of the big
wins
moving on another typical thing that
you're going to see in API documentation
is a try it type component where you can
go get some sort of authorization token
fill in the parameters and hit send API
request and see what the response looks
like now in some cases this might have a
Sandbox environment or sort of a mock
interface that gives you fake
information but it should give you quick
tacti feedback on what is this going to
look like so this kind of gives you a no
code way to try an API and for
developers quite often as a way to
quickly get quick test of what it is
they're thinking and then on the right
you'll notice the request sample so in
this case it's a curl example you could
certainly have language specific code
examples here something that somebody
can copy paste drop into their
application and use as a starting point
for making that call and hopefully this
combination uh significantly reduces the
error rate that new users are going to
experience while this isn't explicitly a
a feature of how you write your
documentation I think from a how to
present documentation this is
increasingly a table Stakes feature that
people expect to see in developer
portals at large especially with
apis coming back to I promised before we
we highlighted where in patri duties API
about listing escalation policies that
they had a link to read about these
Concepts and this is a a snippet from
their documentation of what that looks
like now before we got two lines that
said the list escalation policies gives
you a list of existing escalation
policies and an escalation policy keeps
track of who gets the notification
whatever it was two simple sentences
however in the concepts document we get
a pretty comprehensive description of
what this means and I won't read through
it all here but I think it's a a great
example of where you've got a simple
functional description at top of the the
reference documentation for an operation
that might link back to a more
comprehensive description and internally
if this is an internal focused API you
might also see accompanying links and
material on how this is implemented on
the back end or what other systems it
relies on to make this work for new user
when they look at those couple of
sentences that quick paragraph you still
don't get it you want them to be able to
jump in and get a deeper definition of
what something means and you'll notice
in this case there's many references
that link to other reference material
right at the top user schedule notified
incident Services all of those are other
Concepts and likely other API operations
they will call a group of related things
in order to build a full interaction so
sometimes you need these overviews to
describe how these Concepts relate to
each other and how they're tied together
in fulfilling certain workflows although
we'll come back to that more workflow
oriented view uh it's important not only
to describe beyond the simple paragraph
and have the bigger Concepts but also
what concepts does this relate to or
depend on them the most important
Concept in I think all documentation but
is exceptionally true in API
documentation is how do we get started
this should be the first thing that any
new user who looks for your apis and
comes up on that first page they should
immediately be taken down an enumerated
set of steps here is what I need to do
to call these apis and I say these apis
intentionally to say that it hopefully
isn't a lot of different ways to call a
lot of different apis if there's one way
to provide access that's a win for
everyone from a consumption standpoint I
have one way to do things from a
security standpoint you'll notice right
off the bat the step one and in this
example we switch gears to the stripe
API which I think is probably one of the
strongest examples over the last 10
years or so of excellent API
documentation excellent developer
experience and step one in the stripe
API every call to a stripe AP API must
include an API secret key and then it
goes on to very briefly describe here's
what you need to do to get these API
keys and notice it doesn't say if you're
calling this API do it this way if
you're calling this other API do it that
way one consistent method of off is key
here both in terms of usability and
having a single method accessing these
things so that you can really focus your
effort on securing one areir
area so these steps should lead me down
a road of at the end of a few steps and
hopefully this isn't more than four or
five steps I've made a successful API
call that's really the goal that you're
getting to and in many API programs this
is actually an instrumented thing in
that we want to look at what is the time
to First hello world how long does it
take to get through those first steps
and make the first call and a common
Benchmark is to say this should take no
more than 5 minutes now from a
documentation standpoint this is where
we take hard and make it look easy right
and in some ways we have to really bench
test what we're thinking about on how
people are going to use this and really
simplify and really Whittle things down
to be easy for a new user to adopt so
most important concept this is where you
should be putting a ton of effort I know
I said the errors were the first place
to start but that's in reference this is
more a Concepts so just super key
especially because Step One is almost
always how to do off and as the old
adage goes if you're running a two-day
hackathon day one is getting off done um
this is quite often the inconvenient
difficult tricky part and if you're
building an API and documenting it this
is your riskiest part so you should have
a crystal CER succinct understanding of
how this works for everybody preferably
one way to do it for all apis so that
you comprehend how it works and then you
can explain it succinctly if you can't
do that you probably shouldn't be
publishing it you're probably taking
risks and our final topic tasks again
we'll look at stripe and I said Concepts
and tasks can be a bit of a fuzzy line
but I think the way I think of this is
It's really what is the workflow that
you're trying to here and what is it
that you're trying to do so I often
refer to this as like a showcase
so in strip's case right there top left
they're saying all right do you want to
start an integration and they're
starting with a conceptual idea payment
link checkout web elements that is going
to take you down at the road of learning
some Concepts and learning how to do
those things
together this is really important in the
API world because if you launch
something out there with say reference
material only no Concepts no workflow
driven tasks people will do
serendipitous things right they will
come up with very creative ways to use
your hii that it's in some cases you
didn't plan for and just don't work so
in some ways this is also projecting to
end users this is what this API was
meant to do this is the job that it will
do for you and keeping that frame of
mind for new users will guide them into
using it in the way that you intended
and hopefully not creating friction or
problems for them El or for you not
listed in kind of the big three and this
is because it's not pervasively common
in some ways it's a cost prohibitive
concept for many programs but it's
definitely a key to large scale success
is that if you want quick adoption and
you want API consumers to connect
quickly don't make them write too much
code and you can do that by providing
sdks client libraries tooling around the
API means you don't write code to call
it explicitly you might call a library
you might use a command line interface
things like this and I say these can be
cost prohibitive especially in the
startup world or in smaller companies
building and maintaining client
libraries can be a very costly effort
but you'll notice in Pedro Duty's case
Pedro Duty didn't go build libraries to
interact with its API all languages in
fact many of these came from the pager
Duty Community see you'll notice there's
a warning on here too Community Support
P Duty doesn't endorse or provide
technical support so on this in some
ways is how a lot of folks make this an
affordable approach uh but from a
documentation standpoint it's also an
opportunity for you to Showcase where
there could be Community Options out
there that you didn't build that
ultimately are going to provide a better
experience faster onboarding all that
sort of stuff with the caveat this isn't
stuff we built and so thereby we can't
really directly support it you're going
to have to work with the community on
that but at any rate it is an optional
fourth column that in more mature
programs you'll tend to see this is also
very applicable for internal API
programs as you reach a larger scale a
larger quantity of apis it is definitely
a speed accelerant to have more of these
kind of client libraries command line
tools
So Okay so we've touched on some points
in here about some of the corollary
benefits that you're going to get out of
investing in
documentation most of it in general and
and specific to this class in API
documentation but let's really distill
some of that out and expand on what is
the value so let's say as a learner here
you're thinking about learning about
this concept and you're going to take it
back to uh your team and say this is why
I think we should do this hopefully this
fills your quiver with arrows on Great
Value points for investing in great
documentation so why do we need to do
this and I think we we touched on these
bits the first is it's about education
you've got to teach customers
prospective customers your own employees
potentially Partners about what are the
things that we do and how do you connect
to these things with
apis um it's surprising companies that
lack this sort of platform wide
documentation about all their apis how
you talk to say Business Leaders they
don't really know exactly how things
work they have a general idea but when
you've got one source of Truth to
document things that your company does
you know the capabilities of the apis
provide you have vastly more engaged and
educated leaders and this applies as you
work your way through the organization
especially with apis because it's such a
crosscutting concern through the company
and it's such a distilled representation
of what you do they really important
that everyone understands this and
obviously where the rubber meets the
road on is someone going to adopt this
API or not really essential that you're
able to teach those folks and not just
hand them the encyclopedia and walk
away second you're in part often
defining boundaries between products
within your platform and that
understanding within the
organization can often transcend the way
that you're organized today so we'll
refer to this as like an inverse Conway
maneuver the idea that Conway's law
tells us if one team builds a compiler
you get a one pass compiler if two teams
build a compiler you get a two- pass
compiler in other words if you're not
intentional your software will represent
how you're organized and increasingly
this inverse Conway maneuver says let's
be intentional about what we want the
future of our uh platform to look like
what if we want our capabilities to be
manifested in apis so defining those
boundaries uh can be really important
for people to understand the customer
perspective on what you do and that
could apply for your own employees that
could you know we touched some the
education bit all of that leads
into clearer definition of the things
that you do which is going to heavily
inform how you test and secure those
product boundaries so these things can
you know heavily influence how you're
setting up your network your application
layers all that sort of stuff as well as
at the end of the day again we come back
to does someone want to adopt this thing
they need to understand those boundaries
kind of the groupings of things right so
just comprehensibility the ability for
somebody to look understand the big
picture quickly and then be able to
drill down and understand some of the
details quickly this can be very
powerful organizational amplifier over
time
enabling customer support offerings this
is another factor that isn't really
documentation but you know we're the
front door for these things if someone's
reviewing this API or maybe they've
tried it and they're stuck how do they
get help documentation can help lead
those consumers lead those customers to
find the right kind of support I say the
right kind because sometimes it's
self-help only it's Community Support or
there may be self-service options to go
fix some of of the problems they're
running into if you don't have this sort
of thing then people will wander the
hallways looking for help right meetings
will spawn off everywhere on I'm stuck
how do I get help I need to get on the
phone with somebody I need to get an
email chain going these things are just
friction and toil let's document one
place make it easy to find and finally
supporting technical or developer
marketing efforts in the API World um
you know it's it's a weird thing to
Market to this crowd because you know we
have kind of a low BS threshold but in
short we should be teaching not selling
in kind of technical marketing efforts
and rather than sending some big huge
toe in an email or attaching a PDF we
can link back to
documentation that maybe highlights new
features or points to a change log with
what's the newest change to the CI and
all of those things from a marketing
perspective can help boost adoption
again if you're teaching and not
selling so who benefits from all this
right and we kind of said before that
you could have an internal view of this
you could have an external view of this
sometimes it's both but quite often you
might have different apis that you offer
internally or
externally so the internal value is I
think more than anything avoiding
duplicated effort if you have
undocumented apis all over your
organization there's a good chance that
many of these are going to be built a
not very reusable way and worse if no
one knows what exists there's a tendency
to just look around and if you can't
find it create your own and so you end
up with four different ways to do the
same thing and that's really not good
for anybody right it's not good from a
smart investment standpoint as a company
it's not good for frankly job security
in some cases when these things get
discovered so you know avoiding that
duplicated effort is just such an
obvious win versus not
documenting the second I mentioned
there's a tendency that if you have
undocumented things people will build
oneoff bespoke things is that we can
really promote increasing shared
leverage it's a fancy word to say that
rather than duplicating efforts let's
join forces and build something more
powerful and more
reusable that we can use for a lot of
different scenarios and not maybe just
to enable one partnership or to connect
one system somewhere so that shared
leverage over time will build stronger
capabilities and more aligned
organizations as opposed to fragmented
collections of
ons and finally just beating the dead
horse here on organizational
understanding if you don't document the
apis you have and you have this big
sprawl and we'll talk about that later
nobody really knows how anything works
and it becomes tribal knowledge hallway
discussions and email threads and
meetings trying to chase down does this
exist and how does it work it's just a
huge weight that we can lift off the
organization and really promote a lot of
innovation and and speed as it builds
momentum on the external side again you
might be publishing to a partner Network
or to a wide open publicly facing thing
you obviously have to document something
we're going to dism you it here to say
what's the difference between adequate
documentation and really great and I
think done well
this will promote stronger adoption from
consumers and if you've got and built an
API whether it's directly monetized or
not you're almost always looking for can
we get lots of people to use this right
there's some economy of scale that comes
with this along with that I mentioned
before when you're evaluating an API
that you're going to go use you're
really in some ways evaluating what is
this relationship going to be like and
so let's say you have a hastily clad
document that was a project artifact
written by developers as a second
thought and you're shuttling that over
in a PDF on request that's an a great
way to start a relationship is it so
instead if we have durable documentation
that's there on a well-known URL that's
easy to find and folks are going in and
having a great experience on learning
making that first call less than five
minutes that sort of thing we're off on
the right foot with building a great
relationship with whoever the API
consumer is whether they be developer
off the street or a close partner
relationship all of these things lead to
folks sticking around and being
satisfied having a great developer
experience and finally to the point of
developers when you're marketing
products to developers and in in the API
world we almost always are all the no
code low code is changing that
somewhat folks are going to take away
from that evaluation of looking using an
API is was this a good experience or not
and they're going to tell their friends
and in the developer marketing world we
deeply understand that word of mouth is
key traditional marketing efforts often
drive people away producing great
experiences with thought leaders who
share with their communities is what
builds really big communities around
apis so distilling this down even
further let's try to boil down three big
reasons that we really should be able to
share with folks this is why we have to
do solid
documentation the first is we're going
to look at this from a security
standpoint this is an apis set
curriculum and while it is an explicitly
only about security there's a longer to
documentation it is actually one of the
primary reasons uh is that you can
reduce risk so API exploits and I'm
going to really make a strong call to
action here if you've never heard of
oasp go take a look in general and
specifically the API top 10 was actually
just refreshed in early 2023 the
inconsistent or non-existent off
mechanisms and this is authentication
authorization U these are the reasons at
the very top of the list and they have
been for a long time even in the non-api
top 10 is broken object level
authorization or Bola and broken authen
ation these are reasons one and two that
API exploits are happening and at the
time of putting this together looking
back on 2023 we've had an unprecedented
wave of API exploits and the vast
majority are because of these reasons so
the part that we're going to focus on is
inconsistent and non-existent if you
document an API what's one of the first
things we're going to do getting started
how to get that token and how to attach
that token to the API call if that
doesn't exist and you're writing that
documentation the the flashing red
lights are blasting there is a huge
problem we cannot use this until this is
fixed inconsistent I said before if
you're describing how to get started you
should have one way to do the off
patterns if your documenting the next
API and it does something wildly
different big bright flashing red lights
they're is a problem we have a new way
to do o was that intentional is that a
good idea that is
inconsistent so really just catching
those inconsistent or completely lacking
off mechanisms it is actually one of the
most important ways that you can avoid
API exploits before anything's ever even
in production assuming that you're
documenting these before you release
them and related to that is is joking
that we put here missing mistakes is
that if you're doing this in an
iterative way every time the API is
changed you're updating documentation
that you essentially have audit and
review built into your process now is
your documentation writer always going
to be the expert on what the standards
are and this sort of thing not
necessarily but if you have a more
comprehensive review process that
includes documentation those things
should be caught and we'll talk a little
bit more about kind some ways to build
Bridges from the documentation process
into a broader API design review process
we'll talk about style guides and
standards and these sorts of things but
as you're folks writing documentation
become more familiar with those Concepts
just by the very Act of documenting it
they're going to effectively have done a
high level audit and review so it's a
fantastic place to start in reducing
these
risks second is let's not spawn the army
of zombies and it sounds like a goofy
joke but this is really a thing that
folks refer to in our space is the
prevalence of Shadow or zombie apis and
this in the it and Engineering world
what we're referring to is the apis that
no one knows about and this is
exceedingly a huge
problem is that folks are having to go
dig through logs and look through
production information to try to figure
out what are all the apis we have
because we don't even know what they do
we don't know how they're authenticated
we don't know what their performance is
like these things could be producing
huge risk vectors they could be
producing terrible experiences and
you'll notice here we we provided some
reference to noric apis that 94% of
respondents had experienced some sort of
incident in the last year this is
actually the second big category of risk
is just the undocumented stuff the
things that no one knows exist are the
things that become stale that are not
monitored and just present huge risks
and Blindside opportunities things you
don't even know exist could present
vectors you're not even thinking
about so really we want to build this
catalog of what are the apis what are
the capabilities that we have keep it
maintained have process around it
because if you know what you have you're
able to protect it if you don't even
know it exists who knows what could
happen so taking this concept a little
further we often refer to this notion of
APs
raw and while zombie or Shadow apis are
the things we don't know exist sometimes
sprawl is there might be some idea that
these things exist there may be sporadic
lists of these things floating around or
there's an idea of we kind of know this
is a thing but there's little cognitive
alignment meaning folks don't NE
necessarily have some agreement on what
these things are and how they fit
together as one platform and now that
risk of duplication we talked about
before suddenly becomes a huge problem
is people building really close to the
same thing over and over again and very
little
reusability if we have that better
understanding of what are all the things
and we can see them all in one place
they're documented together there's some
portal that manifests these things we
can start to build that cognitive
alignment the idea that we all
understand Big Ideas in the business
that we run or in the consumer base that
we're serving here that ultimately will
lead to Stronger alignment to Stronger
execution to more satisfied customers
this sort of just reiterate the lack of
visibility it's going to result in less
reusability right if we can see all the
things we'll recognize duplication we'll
recognize where there's shared leverage
potential and we can be more customer
Centric in how we describe things rather
than describing them as a happen stance
way all right so we described our top
reasons that you must have these things
and they're very risky scary and
sometimes that's not the best place to
start in justifying or convincing folks
of why we should do something so let's
talk about the positives the nice to
have what are the benefits of doing this
the first is observability and this is
the antithesis of that sprawl and zombie
stuff we talked about uh it's really the
outcome that we're going for
we want to observability we want to be
able to look at the catalog of things
that we have how they relate to each
other and ultimately have one you know
clear view of so let's say that
observability is the positive outcome
that you're seeking to escape the sprawl
in zombies and Sh leverage already said
this over and over just in the first
section but getting that collaborative
culture together on how to reduce the
wasted effort reduce the duplicated
single use case functionality and really
build powerful reusable capabilities
with your apis this is
essential okay so we have lots of
reasons that we should be doing
documentation and we have an idea of
kind of the the structure of what these
things look like now let's get down to
like who's going to do this who's going
to write the docs and what's an
appropriate choice in how you plan for
writing your API docs and I think this
is true for a lot of technical
documentation and General
to so developers is what we all think of
right it's apis it's technical stuff
developers have to document the thing
they built and the reality on the ground
is that the folks who built the API are
not always great at being able to
describe how it's used seems
counterintuitive but let's say that when
you're building it you have a system
Centric View and when you're consuming
it you don't know anything about those
systems and so there's a tendency that
implementers will think more about how
it was built rather than how it's used
and it's very difficult for them to
escape those thought patterns that's not
a knock that's not a criticism it's just
a reality at a bare minimum we should
have some kind of peer review related
teams or teams that are planning to use
these things at least providing that
contrasting view of here's what it looks
like from the
outside now a pro of having Developers
invol in the documentation and frankly I
don't think you should try to escape
developers involved inting
apis is that if a developers
implementing the apis partnered well
with other folks they can be great about
providing developer Centric feedback
especially in this peer review type
stuff we're describing another developer
looking at what when developer bill will
produce a better outcome you're going to
have something that is going to have a
Viewpoint that's about writing code that
no one else can really provide in the
organization so next in typical truct
development we might see product
managers who are involved and
increasingly we see the role of API
product managers being a thing now over
the last four or five years we see this
job description increasingly popping up
everywhere so we describe this as
occasionally who will write the docs the
pro of doing it this way is that you
have a very customer centered
perspective compared to say a developer
who's building it so that can really
ultim provide an effective developer
experience and this goes back to before
where we said developers try business
buys is you need that clear functional
description and sometimes developers get
into kind of the sausage making side of
it rather than being a little more
empathetic to the end user product
managers are often naturally better at
this thing now the obvious con is if you
have say very non-technical product
managers that lack of technical
expertise could lead to some problematic
ways they would describe things and this
is again where putting those PMs and
developers together and partnership to
describe these things can be
effective now who should write the docs
we talked about what kind of tends to
happen you know dev's building the API
and wres the documentation of the task
on Project or the PM maybe kicks in and
helps out and cleans it up and makes it
readable for customers I think you can
get to perfectly adequate outcomes for
that that are L effective however I
think in a perfect world with no budget
constraints I reach for technical
writers especially those if you're doing
apis who've done it before and
understand the
intricacies so that the pros is like I
don't think it's it's well described
here but it's to say that we have real
professionals who understand how to
communicate technical Concepts and ideas
and how to be precise and thorough
describing all the things it is a smart
investment period or around apis in my
opinion and I think it's really
underutilized in so many companies it
always surprises me when I find
companies that don't even have technical
writers so if you're going to reach for
that and say let's go hire Tech writers
to help with this great call but keep in
mind that you can't have a team go
Implement and build a whole apil row it
over the fence to a tech riter and
expect magic to happen you've got to
have those writers involved early in the
process and you've got to have some sty
guide defined around this so that
they're enabled to produce consistent
results so document the simple basic
stuff as soon as you know it even in the
abstract for any implementation has
happened and then iterate to release
that will produce all those benefits in
Tech writers being implicit QA they're
going to find problems as they document
things don't do all that at the end and
treat a lot of friction and delivery do
that from the beginning and find those
problems while you're
developing all right so onto our second
section we've established now what is an
API who writes those things why we
should be doing it all these benefits
but let's really break this down in in
strong terms on what's the impact to a
business in investing in API
documentation so we already referenced
before good docs matter to security
reviewing those off patterns consistency
these sorts of things you're going to
find security
issues and consistency I keep saying
that word let's break that down a little
bit more a lot of folks talk about
standardization and really consistency
in some ways is the outcome of
standardizing want to have things that
look and feel the same and in the
business of building platforms the main
difference between just a bunch of apis
and something that feels like a platform
is that
consistency so investing in docs is
going to show where you have those
inconsistencies especially if you've got
professional Tech writers involved
consistency is the name of the game and
they're going to see those things
clear's day quality I I keep saying that
those who write docs for an API Through
The Eyes of a consumer will find quality
problems they're going to find bad error
handling issues they're going to find
logical problems and how the API works
and they're going to provide that
functional view so we talked about those
first few sentences in each reference
material that describe what this thing
does and the concepts that amend that
all of that can be incredibly use for
someone who's working on how are we
going to test this and make sure that
that it's at adequate quality if we
don't know all those things early then
how are we expected to test it at
adequate quality and it's more secure we
are leaving less room for error if we
just go build an API undocumented and
get ready to release and say oh security
Ops Dev Ops can you uh check this out
it's a terrible way to start that
engagement and if they find problems
then it becomes a fight because I've got
to ship this thing customers are
expecting it business is expecting it
security and devop hooks you're holding
me up that's no good right if we're able
to provide documentation about what we
intend this thing to be even if it's
rough documentation early in the process
those teams are more aware they can plan
they can prepare they can do deeper
Dives more questions without holding up
delivery and by actually documenting the
things we ship the security and devops
folks are given a fighting chance
against the army of zombies or the
sprawl problems if they're never even
made aware and someone just pushes code
and there's no documentation for it how
can they be expected to do a great job
in defending those
assets so in simple terms here at the
bottom bad poorly maintained
non-existent documentation these this is
a leading risk for security
exposures so while we're saying that
consistency standardization is good
sometimes so scope are we just make try
to make things too perfect I don't think
in this case we're looking for
Perfection we're looking for existence
and reasonable quality right let's
reduce those risks there's no such thing
as no risk but at least having
reasonable documentation is going to
heavily mitigate the risk that we have
unmonitored
assets so let's dig a little more into
security right if we're taking this
approach that we should document things
and Design things before we build them
and I know that's that sounds a little
counterintuitive a little cart before
the horse but it's not to say that we
have perfect documentation day one
before we build anything or that we have
a perfect design before we've built
anything it's that we should have a
basic understanding of what this thing
will do what it will look like before we
go and get too far into implementation
and realize there's problems and what's
key about this in the security realm is
we can review off patterns before a line
of code has been written and that in
itself is one of the most powerful ideas
in probably addressing 80% of API equids
now if you didn't document anything you
didn't design up front and you just went
off and built something and shipped it
to
production you just lost that 80% B so
Security review is a pretty commonly
understood thing what we would suggest
here is with this documentation first
design first mindset as soon as you can
describe the thing that you're going to
build let's start engaging in some kind
of security Ry
process so how do we do that API style
guides are are a big step in the right
direction and we're going to take a
little closer look at what those look
like but this in essence is saying that
we have some standardized patterns in
how we design our apis especially
including how we do o so if your API
design review incorporates security and
you have some automation around style
guides and these sort of things you can
put a lot of really sophisticated look
at things very early in the process and
really cut off a lot of the problems
that tend to emerge when this acument is
not
addressed one weapon here as we describ
it in your repository can be security
style guide and so really this is a
subset of a broader API I to say that
how do we do these security Centric
things and I keep talking about off but
there could be lots of other security
related things in your apis for instance
if it's a payment related API making
sure that you don't have some exploit
available to say manipulate currencies
or you know some scenario that you need
to be very cautious about you should
have some defined standards tend to call
this style guide because I don't know
standards make people bristle saying
that there's a style in which we design
things I think is more appropriate to a
design discipline so all of that can
help put some guard rails around the
design process and incorporate security
early with that early documentation so
that everyone understands what we're
going to do everyone understands the
risks
earlier and ultimately at the end here
with a a well chosen set of rules around
your security
and enforceable sounds a little rough
here but it's just to say that do we
have process that plugs in those rules
somewhere that you can keep using these
tools in an iterative way to keep just
building stronger defenses into the
future and not constantly be digging a
deeper
hole so all of this is taking us down a
road here and you know we're going to
have to say the GW I know it's not
always popular but I insist we should
reclaim the word governs and make it
what it needs to be into the future and
not the painful thing some of us have
experienced from the past so a healthy
documentation process is a great way to
start moving toward having stronger
governance and this is where we'll dig
into kind of that style guide thing that
I keep referring to this is about
automating consistency we keep saying
that when we look across a bunch of apis
that consistency is the only thing that
makes it feel like a platform that they
all look feel smell touch the same
manually maintaining that it's it's
risky it's hard um as somebody who has
done many manual API reviews I know I've
always missed stuff it's impossible to
catch it all we are not great as humans
at finding these things so we should
really be looking at how can we put more
automation around these things so
consistency standardization these things
live together but how do we do that so
the First with style guide and linking
approaches is key one example of this it
happens to be an open source project of
stop lights so it does sound like I'm
Shilling but I can objectively say that
this is a broadly adopted artifact in
the open source Community to Define
governance rule sets and I think the
reason it's really relevant in our
learning about API documentation is
there's actually do documentation
Centric rule sets that you can use that
do things like have all the description
Fields been filled out for all the the
fields in your response if that's
something that you want to set a rule
for and so you see here on the right an
example of what a stal guide looks like
and how the errors might manifest so for
instance here at the top of the rules it
says info contact info object should
contain a contact object that might
actually be a great documentation rule
for let's say an internal API is okay I
found the API I know what it does I read
the documentation and there's something
I still don't get who can I contact to
find out more right so you might want to
standardize and say that there should
always be contact information with every
API listed so could you do that manually
and say oh make sure that we've always
got contact information sure you might
miss it and let's be honest no one
really wants to do that manual review so
put it on a check we can manifest an
error somewhere that'll show folks hey
don't forget to have this and then by
the time you sit down to do some sort of
manual review for the things you can't
automate you don't have to worry about
that this is a huge Force multiplier for
kind of all things apis but surprisingly
even in the documentation world we can
do a lot of good here another suggestion
from Talking Tech writers is Veil so
Veil is basically another kind of
linting engine for enforcing writing
style so quite often you're going to
develop a voice a certain you might
adhere to say Microsoft's technical
writing guideline something along those
lines and you want to be able to turn on
a rule set that says here is how we
phrase certain Concepts or here's when
we use acronyms and we don't things like
that so point being with a few different
tools and there certainly are some more
out there but I think these these are
some really leading strong ones you can
make the review process predominantly
automated so you can spend all of your
cognitive energy on a stuff that matters
what does this thing dude should it be
here is it reusable and not did you
remember the contact info did use an
acronym or not so all of this leads down
the road of stronger scaling we can
replicate this kind of process this kind
of automation on all the things that we
do and ultimately it should lead us down
a road of more reusable things things
that you don't have to write BB code
every time you use a different
API and all of this too should lead
toward something that's just pleasing to
a developer's eye you know developers
can't help but be precise in our nature
right in building big complex things
with lots of things to remember we love
consistency we love to be able to look
at something and go ah that is so
pleasing there's nothing out of place
everything's where it should be um and
these kinds of approaches and automating
your consistency it's an intangible
difficult to measure thing but it really
can produce a much better developer
experience another concept here we
talked a little bit about how there's
internal and external apis and I keep
mentioning partner networks this sort of
thing in the world of Partnerships
documentation is one of the most
important assets that you're going to
trade in the early phases is hey you
want to partner with us here's how you
would integrate so for those potential
Partners who might be looking at your
partner portal there's a few things that
you can really punch through here one is
brand affinity and this is where we
talked about you might want to have a
little more customization on the
external facing stuff if they don't ever
get documentation and they're having to
constantly ask questions that's a
terrible uh relationship so that's a bad
starting point let's give them something
that's our best forward but there're
also just going to be in a way
evaluating your company and how you
operate by their interaction here so
there is an implied kind of brand
Affinity so when folks talk about loving
strip right uh in the developer world
this is a common sentiment it's because
they had a great experience with that
documentation they didn't have to ask
anyone questions they were able to
accomplish their goal without help they
have a love for that brand so that's one
of these tough to measure tricky and
tangible things but really is something
you have to keep in mind the second and
I've said this a few times that API
adoption if you don't know anything else
about an API that's the first thing you
should measure is if we went to all the
trouble to build this thing these are
not always easy things to build or
people using it do we have a good Trend
going that people are getting value from
it so docs are your best tactic to push
that adoption you have a crappy docks
experience I promise promise it will be
worse adoption than if you had a great
experience and then finally is scaling
and we talk about some of the processes
and things that should dovetail into
your documentation efforts and you're
not going to be able to reach scale if
you don't kind of have that game
together and if you have a bunch of
undocumented one andof crappy
relationships you're going to struggle
to scale this program so documentation
is and often you know not thought about
strongly as it's a critical asset in
producing that
scale so let's dig into the simple
question of how do we write good
documentation I think we've touched on a
few of these different subjects we' hit
it from a few angles let's get a little
more practical so again just reminder we
want to think about who's the the
audience here are these
internal developer oriented documents
are they end consumers who might be
external to the company are there any
sort of security gates involved these
are all things we want to keep in mind
before we enter into this so it's always
important start with those relationships
understand who's going to be using it so
that you're using the right voice and
the right approach and enabling them
some high level things on as you're
sitting down to document an API a couple
of high Lev things to think about first
is an explanation of what request data
is required what's optional an example
might be the version of your API this is
commonly passed in a path there's
certainly other approaches like headers
uh but this is often required
information you need to supply which
version it is that you want to get um
and if it's not required that's also
important uh and what happens if I don't
Supply a version do I get the latest and
an auto upgrades me how does all that
work important to explain along the same
lines Authentication any other uh sort
of headers or anything that are to be
expected the path to call each endpoint
think this is the most seminal
information in calling an API is what's
that URL going to look like what HTTP
methods are going to be used get postl
delete the options could be other things
and the request data fields what's the
request body look like are there things
besides the body like query stream
parameters that might be
passed on the other side we need to look
at what's expected in the response which
responses will always be there what am I
going to get when I call this thing so
example data always really useful as a
an easy way to go beyond the
documentation to what does this actually
look like what status codes are possible
I will'll definitely look at this in
kind of a more real example but as we've
said before it's not always the 200 okay
that comes back sometimes we run into
problems so we get errors like 400s or
500 class errors those are all different
status codes that could occur and it's
important to document what all those
possibilities are and if there's any
sort of status code or any other
information that comes back what does it
mean in the context of this call is
there's something specific to
it and again documenting one API is one
thing but we also want to think about
where are we sending folks when we write
this document and I hope that the answer
is is not we're going to email them
because that's just it's not really
acceptable these days we want to be able
to send them a URL to here's all the
apis you can find the thing that you
looking for so we're really talking
about death portals and things like this
so think about how are people going to
find these things is it discoverable as
you're sitting down to write your
documentation you want to think about
who's going to read it and test it out
and this is where some form of developer
advocacy
is important and there's a lot of
different ways to organize this and put
this into action but at a bare minimum
have other internal developers read
through the documents even if you don't
have sort of developer relations
developer advocacy who might be your
contacts in the field who talk to end
users a lot a little pizza and beer can
go a long way recruit some folks who
were not on the team building the API to
go look through and try to follow the
documentation and see what they run into
and if possible observe them doing it
where are they running into sticky spots
friction where are they struggling to
understand what to do next are they
getting caught up in terms they don't
understand and having to go read
definitions and hunt for that
information as we've said before what we
expect is probably don't get the off
right the first time this is a common
story and again we want to have that be
step one in getting started but making
sure that not only is that documented
but someone's tested it out who isn't
writing the docs and who isn't building
the API to make sure that it actually
works in reality because if that one
thing breaks nothing else works so
you've got to get that right above all
other things so with that let's go make
a fake API let's go create something you
know at least partially from scratch and
see what this looks like in practice so
let's take a look at our imaginary
API in this case we're going to create a
widget API obviously our descriptions
are not going to be very verbose as they
widgets a fairly Indescribable thing but
from the top we see that already defined
uh aversion we've come up with a base
URL as well as a mock server URL this
basically just means that we can call a
fake API before it's actually been
created information about security any
additional information about who to
contact any license information that
might be applicable terms of service and
from the top again we want to provide a
simple basic description of what this
thing does what is a widget right tell
me that in this case there's not much to
say getting started we talked about this
before that in an overview of an API I
should know what to do to go use it and
in this case the only real prerequisite
is making sure that I've done the off
stuff and made up how that would work if
it actually
existed typical usage just gives me an
idea of why people would use this thing
right uh and again the description isn't
terribly relevant here but this gives us
an idea of content placeholders and then
Concepts I've already kind of predefined
and we'll look at it the idea that
anywhere that we have a list of things
that we would have uh some simple paging
controls like page and Page size as
query parameters we'll see this in the
actual
definition so let's look at the retrieve
all widgets endpoint this is basically
basically my get SL
widgets so I immediately get information
on what I need to do to call the thing
that's straightfor description retrieve
a list of all widgets widgets are blah
right uh made something up here and
reiterating that this is pageable list
that you get back security information
yet again and this is going to be one of
those things that you really got to have
on every operation you really want to
show folks very clearly that you're
going to have to do this security stuff
in order to call it
a description of how those query
parameters for paging work and of course
what do we get back in the response when
I get SL widgets the paging
information's here on page and total
Pages at the top but you'll note that we
didn't just say page integer total Pages
integer done so not only do we have the
data type we describe what this does how
it works like in this case it'll match
your request query parameter if it was
available otherwise the default is one
and our example total Pages this is
basically how many were available it
tells me basically it supports up to 100
pages and there's an example there of
10 the items that come back in that
array of widgets a widget has an ID a
name and a skew these are all strings
but you'll notice on the right here the
name is required the skew is required in
this case it's a a response so it seems
a little odd it'll make more sense when
we go to actually create something this
is basically saying these fields should
be populated again we see examples
provided on what you would typically
expect these to look like and in the
case of name it tells us that it has to
be more than one character less than 50
so we have an idea of what the range of
available data is and in the skew
there's actually a match pattern or
regular expression that tells us here's
the format that's required for this
information now I noticed I missed the
description on name so we can go fix
that before we get started on the rest
but let's go ahead and
edit now obviously we're using the stop
platform to do this because I'm
comfortable this is easy you can do this
any number of ways for the sake of a
rapid example this is a quick way for me
to show you the kinds of things to look
at so let's go down and you'll notice
here that in my response body for the
I can see what its contents are but it
sits great out and it's because I've
linked to a shared definition here in
components and we can see it over here
on the left widgets list paged is here
and that's really just an array of
widget objects are referenced from here
so I can go take a look at the widget uh
and let's go fix that
name
attribute so we got a description there
there which is
good so we can always preview take a
look make sure yep there's the
name uh were we missing an example yeah
that's it so go over here click on this
and we can provide an
example fidget name there we go so
here's some examples of things uh in
open API that you can sort of specify we
could say if there was a specific format
like if this was a date or whatever um
we can set up what a default value would
be in this case I'm going to say that
there is no default widget name you have
to supply it um there's no particular
pattern that it's checking but there's a
max length of 50 Min length of one so
this is kind of behind the curtain of
you know some of this things that we saw
in the docs
view okay so I fixed that I'm going to
go ahead and publish the
change uh but we can look at this in
preview and see now that uh I have my
example on my widget name so this is a
good kind of story here that we've
always got examples provided any
constraints defined whether or not it's
required so you know just having the
list of fields on something is only
marginally useful without this
additional context that lets consuming
developers understand you know beyond
what you generally mean are there very
specific constraints that I have to
comply with Okay so let's go back to our
API for retrieving all the widgets and
now we want to go take a look at
creating a new operation for this API so
I'm going to say we can get all the
widgets let's go create one and so post
uh is what in HTTP we would use to
create something so let's do add a post
operation and we'll say here create a
widget okay that is a post to SL widgets
the same URL we call to get the list
let's make sure that we have a
description so the description let's say
create
a new widget Supply the name notice this
is markdown based in this platform uh so
by putting the tix it's going to put
kind of a little Cod view we'll see that
in preview when I tab away uh and
skew andd will be
autogenerator okay so that give us some
idea of you know what do I have to do
here in this case it's simple enough I'm
going to effectively double describe
what we're going to do in real practice
you might want to have something a
little more practical and useful as to
why you would do this
thing so security we don't have to
Define here because this is set up
globally you'll notice on the right it's
already showing security information
here but in this case I do need to
request body so let's go ahead and
Define a body now uh I obviously don't
want it to be a generic object I'm going
to go ahead and go pick widget uh that
we already defined over here in our
sidebar as kind of a a shared thing
between these operations so I don't have
to redefine all that stuff so we see now
here that the body uh has ID named skew
and uh name and skew are really what's
required um and in fact in a real world
scenario we probably wouldn't show the
ID here but I don't want to make the
example too complicated so let's just
say that this is the shape of object we
have to pass those two fields are what's
required um in a 200 okay scenario what
would we to respond with um it's
somewhat likely uh it's fair to say that
we might want to return the widget back
right uh here's what you asked to be
sent here's what we send
back um we make sure that the type is
correct sure application Jason fair
enough um now in many cases you know you
will just kind of in the response say
okay you could certainly do more uh we
could say something like the widget has
SP
[Music]
successfully
created achieve the
autogenerated ID from the
response
okay uh so now in our preview we start
to see this kind of flushing out and you
know we might look at this and say cool
great like uh you know what the request
body is and the fields that you need to
supply what's required um and you know
what you're going to get back we're
done but let's remember what's the first
most likely thing that our consuming
developer is going to run
into well let's think about
adding say a 400 error bad request what
if uh you know we made a mistake when we
posted uh that request body so let's
make sure that that uh body that we
respond with again I've predefined kind
of a common error for the whole platform
uh so just by specifying that now all
this stuff is predefined for
me I certainly could in some cases
provide more context in this description
as to what the errors are and in this
standard error object we would uh
probably describe what happened in that
specific error it's also not a bad idea
by the way and I didn't do it in this
example to describe your errors as
Concepts in your getting started kind of
area of your documentation
I would say the bare minimum we should
have our 400 we should probably have 401
unauthorized uh oops let's put that back
to 400 and we'll create a new one not
mistake so let's create a new response
on
401 uh and again I'm I'm just always
going to have every error come back with
the same model I think this is generally
accepted best practice if you have an
API that suddenly has a whole different
way of doing errors from everything else
you've done might might want to talk to
the developers who built it and make
sure that we're following some kind of a
standardized approach okay so I've got
my 40 400 which is generally the the
client provided something wrong in the
request 401 which says you were
unauthorized um you know you haven't
sort of logged in in some fashion uh you
don't have an API token perhaps at all
403 is perhaps you supplied a token but
you didn't have access so let's describe
some of this stuff right and this is the
trick is you got to think why would this
happen so API key was provided but uh
access to this
resource was not
authorized can say API key missing or
invalid okay and then finally we should
make sure that we've covered the 500 uh
and so all those other things were what
did the client do wrong uh and 500 is
essentially something happened wrong on
the server uh file a support
ticket for more he let's say that that's
our support flow so now when I go look
at my responses over here uh I've got my
200 and the description of the body uh
but if I go look at my 400 my 401 my 403
and my 500 uh those have been described
well enough that I've at least provided
some context to users of here's what
you're going to see when errors occur
and granted if done well you're going to
get this generic error object look at
its contents to understand what's
happened okay and I'm going to go ahead
and publish these changes and we'll go
back and look at kind of the docs view
for it and see what this looks like all
together so now on my left side I've got
the get all widgets uh I've got my
description of how that works and I can
go look at creating a new widget uh
again we see there's security
information request body information and
my response is both successful and
unsuccessful Another Thing Worth
pointing out here now that we've kind of
got this fully rendered out um another
sort of let's say portal feature you
should be looking for um is like say in
this case can I call a fake API that
emulates what this would look like if I
really did it if I really called this
with this body supplied here's what I
would get back um and for consuming
clients can I get uh code samples
perhaps in different languages uh or
just a curl call so I can try this
command line um and examples of what the
response looks like without having to do
the try it thing right uh so these are
all generally expected kinds of features
um that go beyond what your job would be
as documenting an API but I think how
you would render and provide good
context for how to consume this we're
going to go back and look at our widgets
apis again we had our retrieve all
widgets our create a widget let's look
at the one that we created I'm going to
go in and headed
this and look at kind of what's under
the covers here um you know we kind of
focused on just getting through the
documentation filling in the blanks
making sure that we did all the the
basics for this example but I'm actually
going to switch over to our code view
here and this is actually what we're
producing kind of under the covers let
me turn off the preview so we have more
Viewpoint um so this is using open API
3.1 and you'll notice like there's an
info section where we can fill in title
version summary description all those
things we were doing we can see the
servers where we showed that widget
server as what folks would use to call
this as well as our paths
so underneath paths we have SL widgets
and then you'll notice we go into the
verbs the get and we should have down
here a post within our get ver basally
our summary or we can put our
description the individual response
codes we have our 200 400 500 that we
defined as well as descriptions for each
of those and what the content type
coming back is again we typically see
application Jason on newer development
and the
schema in this case it gets a little bit
tricky looking because I had defined a
shared way of defining the widget
response object and request object that
we could link everywhere and this is how
open API does it is this sort of dollar
ref language that uses Jason pointer to
play over to that we've also got a
description of what that looks like this
is what it's going to look like if
you're writing raw open API obviously
you can go read up on the open API spec
and better understand how to structure
these things and I should point out to
that that ref where we had a link here
um you know in this case it's a a
specific sort of stoplight way of
resolving it for those workspace wide
sharables but in this case we're just
pointing this widget list paged which if
we go down to the bottom here we'll see
components and schemas are defined in
here for the widget as well as widget
paged and these are really no different
than defining it in line with the
operation but just to break it down a
little bit we've got our widget it's got
title what type of object it is so in
this case it's just a generic object and
then the properties these are
essentially the fields or ID or name or
skew um what those types are whether
they're string or number so like down
here in our widget list page for a page
number it's an integer not a
string and things like pattern where we
talked about that we have a a regular
expression to make sure that this is 10
to 20 combination letters and numbers
examples are provided in the field as
well and of course our description in
this case because I use stoplight we've
got this stoplight thing that's an
extension that goes beyond open API and
youly wouldn't put that in if you're not
using stop light platform and it's
autogenerated for you but that we've
also got here at the bottom the security
schemes where we're specifying
authorization and this applies to
everything here and yeah so that gives
you an idea of what it looks like to
look directly at the open API you know
ultimately when you're putting the
content in here it's marked down so
you'll notice like pound for headers
double pound for second tier headers
pretty simple stuff if you've ever
looked at mark down for again that's an
easy one to go Google look and see how
it works but you you're generally going
to see folks using markdown in here and
then your portal rendering software
whatever you're using is going to read
that markdown and render it into
something that's formatted and that's
how we kind of end up for instance where
uh we have these headers defined so we
look at our widgets overview we look at
that preview like the getting started
typical usage how these things get
rendered out so fairly straightforward
you know call me lazy I like having this
view where I don't have to do all that
syntax uh but certainly there's nothing
wrong with learning it and it's probably
a good skill if you're working on
documenting
apis we're going to go back and look at
our widgets apis again we had our
retrieve all widgets our create a widget
let's look at the one that we created
I'm going to go in and headit
this and look at kind of what's under
the covers here um you know we kind of
focused on just getting through the
documentation filling in the blanks
making sure that we did all the the
basics for this example but I'm actually
going to switch over to our code view
here and this is actually what we're
producing kind of under the covers let
me turn off the preview so we have more
Viewpoint um so this is using open API
3.1 and you'll notice like there's an
info section where we can fill in title
version summary description all those
things we were doing we can see the
servers where we showed that widget
server as the what pugs would use to
call this as well as our paths so
underneath paths we have SL widgets and
then you'll notice we go into the verbs
a get and we should have down here a
post within our get ver Bally our
summary or we can put our description
the individual Response Code so we have
our 200 400 500 that we defined as well
as descriptions for each of those and
what the content type coming back back
is again we typically see application
Jason on newer development and the
schema in this case it gets a little bit
tricky looking because I had defined a
shared way of defining the widget
response object and request object that
we could link everywhere and this is how
open API does it is this sort of dollar
ref language that uses Jason pointer to
play over to that we've also got a
description of what that looks like this
is what it's going to look like if
you're writing raw open API obviously
you can go read up on the open API spec
and better understand how to structure
these things and I should point out too
that that ref where we had a link here
um you know in this case it's a a
specific sort of stoplight way of
resolving it for those workspace wide
sharables but in this case we're just
pointing this widget list paged which if
we go down to the bottom here we'll see
components
and schemas are defined in here for the
widget as well as widget paged and these
are really no different than defining it
in line with the operation but just to
break it down a little bit we've got our
widget it's got title what type of
object that it is so in this case it's
just a generic object and then the
properties these are essentially the
fields or ID or name or skew um what
those types are whether they're string
or a number so like down here in our
widget list page for a page number it's
an integer not a
string and things like pattern where we
talked about that we have a a regular
expression to make sure that this is 10
to 20 combination letters and numbers
examples are provided in the field as
well and of course our description in
this case because I use stoplight we've
got this stoplight thing that's an
extension that goes beyond open API and
youly wouldn't put that in if you're not
using stoplight platform and it's
autogenerated for you but that we've
also got here at the bottom the security
schemes where we're specifying an
authorization and this applies to
everything here and yeah so that gives
you an idea of what it looks like to
look directly at the open API you know
ultimately when you're putting the
content in here it's marked down so
you'll notice like pound for headers
double pound for second tier headers
pretty simple stuff if you've ever
looked at markdown before again that's
an easy one to go Google look see how it
works but you you're generally going to
see folks using markdown in here and
then your portal rendering software
whatever you're using is going to read
that mark down and render it into
something that's formatted and that's
how we kind of end up for instance
where're uh we have these headers
defined so we look at our widgets
overview we look at that preview like
the getting started typical usage how
these things get rendered out right so
fairly straightforward you know call me
lazy I like having this view where I
don't have to do all that syntax uh but
certainly there's nothing wrong with
learning it and it's probably a good
skill if you're working on documenting
apis now that we've gone and tried out
creating an API and and documenting it
let's dig in a little bit deeper and go
through some of the details so again
rest API documentation is what we're
generally focused on here certainly
there are nuances to other forms of apis
but one thing that we just kind of did
in that example and we'll go back and
look at it again here in a second is um
we didn't start with say a Google doc or
an HTML file or you know something from
scratch and like hand write like putting
the API on one side and a text editor on
the other and writing documentation from
scratch we used a tool that helped us
walk through sort of filling in the
blanks and the point to this is and
curated content can be very difficult to
scale consistent approaches across an
organization so using something that
generates the documentation for you
means you can quickly create some
internal reference you saw there in just
a few minutes we were able to go Define
our API and we could easily go share a
link out to that to anybody else to go
look at we need to be able to easily and
rapidly make changes when those changes
occur in the
API and ultimately we need to make sure
that the API docs match the
functionality um this is actually one of
the more common things I've said before
that like broken off stuff is a really
common one but right behind it is the
API docs don't actually match reality
because we didn't have a process to
capture change or we just didn't get it
right in the first
place so one really powerful way to do
this with rest API is open API formerly
know known as Swagger is a way to
describe an API without actually
implementing or building one and that's
what actually we just did uh and we'll
kind of go back and take a look under
the covers what ises that open API look
like I just certainly prefer to not have
to look at that syntax by default and
just use a tool for me but the point is
that open API is structured in a way
that you can tie into your code base you
can tie into other tools make sure that
in an automated way everything matches
so just to take another look at what API
reference looks like when done well
obviously in our little example that
wasn't the most uh flushed out API in
the case of stripes this is what most
folks point to as a company they sign it
incredibly well from the start each
operation has this humanfriendly
description when I look here I know I
create a charge I charge a credit card
or other payment Source I create a
charge option object right it's very
prun right it gives me an easy way to
understand what it is that I need to
do and there's also that copy paste
example sample call stuff here on the
right so this these again are pretty
typical things folks expect out of the
API documentation experience if you want
to go look at what good looks like go
take a look
strip another great example is twio um
you know this is I think number two on
the list of very successful API programs
that have been largely driven by their
developer portal kind of developer
experience they've always been brilliant
at providing lots of language specific
examples so on the panel there on the
right you see it's provided in PHP you
can change that language and their
coverage is quite
tremendous and I I know on the back end
they're actually testing those examples
every time they deploy changes so those
are those examp examples work right um
so you want to keep that stuff visible
while you're browsing the documentation
so that as you're beginning to
understand how it works it's easy enough
to reach over hit copy paste or you know
in some cases even click the try it
button and and go do
it so let's take a broader look I said
before that um you know there are lots
of other techniques and tools and things
like that uh so let's take a quick look
at those so from a technique standpoint
I think we've been kind of assuming in
the course of discussing this that we're
designing an API that has not been built
yet so right here in the middle put kind
of a spec based approach you know using
open API like I talked about that's an
example of an API specification
format one of the advantages is
especially if you're sharing these docs
in a centralized place it minimizes
duplicated effort if you're sharing a
spec that you're planning to go build
everyone's able to see it and thereby
you can join forces or go work on
something else don't accidentally build
the same thing you can get earlier
feedback on something before you've
invested in building it find out if it's
going to work for the the community
that's going to consume it the cons are
it is possible that if you implement it
different than the spec you could get
out of sync so there's certainly some
mitigating approaches to address that on
the left here we have code annotations
this is a pretty widely popular thing
for many years I think it's in some ways
kind of on its way out in preference in
favor of spec based but still widely out
there and this is the idea that you
actually go into the code and drop
annotations into the code that describe
what each operation does so obviously
the disadvantage here is for especially
someone like a tech writer or product
manager having to go into a code base
and make changes can be a little
intimidating on the upside the code
code's going to match the docs if you're
generating documentation from code
annotations um so it's it's harder to
get out of sync and there's not any
extra sort of tooling or steps that
you're going to have to do again the
other big downside is you've got to
actually go Implement code you've got to
have probably Engineers involved in at
least stubbing this out before you can
even begin documenting and perhaps
providing mocks or
something um on the right here is more
of that hand curated B spoke approach
it's like you're not using any specs
you're not using any annotations you're
just starting with simple so say content
management platform and plugging in your
own format for all that stuff it's easy
and that you don't have to have any
fancy tools you don't have to learn any
kind of specs or know how to get into
code document things and just about any
CMS will publish any form of
documentation but it is really really
difficult to keep anything in sync and
there's nothing contract based so
there's no other tooling Downstream
that's going to be able to integrate
with that process so this is you know
labor of love to keep it in good shape
and you're going to have to do all the
kind of format and design aspects to
make that in a format people expect
especially when you start going down the
road about having code samples
or you know triy it components those are
things that generic cms's just not going
to give you um you would have to go
custom build certainly say in 2023
that's probably not a great
idea so tools that are out there um
obviously I have to you know plug the
stoplight platform here a bit and
primarily because we have a lot of open
source and free options available but I
would certainly point out that there's
lots of great API doation platforms out
there uh red doly and readme have always
been pretty documentation focused uh so
it's certainly one of their strong
points Swagger hubs very similar to
stock light and having bigger set of
functionality it goes beyond docks and
in the perspective that maybe you just
go do something a little simpler Notions
out there but you know probably not
nearly as strong because it's a more
Boke hand curated approach but I would
certainly say you know going and doing
this stuff from scratch writing specs by
hand or building your Portal from
scratch I mean there are so many options
and I would say even just looking at
GitHub um you know there's so many
opsource portal generators that will
take like an API spec file like open API
and render that documentation for you I
really couldn't advise more against
going and doing this all from
scratch so from there let's get into a
little bit more of the best practice
stuff we touched on some of the the
checklist kind of things that you should
always be doing first of all you've got
to think about broad audience so it's
important that your internal jargon is
not leaking into this documentation in a
way that's going to be disorienting for
those consuming it now if you're
building internal oriented stuff I think
this is somewhat more permissible uh to
use sort of jargon or acronyms but the
reality is you should really fight
against that Trend um because you can't
always count on the fact that everybody
in the company knows all these terms and
having to go to some big dictionary to
look up what it means it's friction
filled would certainly advise challenge
yourself to look past jargon and
acronyms and be more clear help include
folks that might not understand those
things un approachable tone and plain
language I think you know sometimes
folks get caught up in lots of buzzword
Bingo and business e sounding stuff and
especially with developers using these
things there's commonly a much more
downto Earth straightforward way of
talking and I think it can be good in
terms of building that relationship with
the consuming developer that he this is
you know this is a friendly place to
be using clear variable names function
names and code samples um you know this
this starts to get a little bit detailed
But ultimately you don't want to have
some generated sample that's you look at
it and just don't really know what it
means so being thoughtful about
providing samples and that sort of thing
can really help clarify what it is that
I'm about to copy paste and use be alert
to discriminatory language increasingly
there's an awareness that there's words
that we might use in you know especially
in the traditional software world that
increasingly folks might be a little
insulted or offended by uh so put your
best foot forward and make sure that
you're not using that kind of language
and making the best first
impression practical guides multimedia
elements so we've talked before that the
reference material it's just not enough
you've got to have this sort of walk
through of here's the set of things need
to go do in order to accomplish your use
case so having things that are a little
more practical in the outcome that I
expect to get from this rather than a
sort of mechanical you know go find all
the pieces and glue them together
yourself and multimedia elements here is
really referring that you can include
videos and maybe gifts whatever
multimedia ways of delivering your
content so you can certainly go above
and beyond all of this content writing
that we've been talking about and really
provide something that's perhaps more
engaging to different kinds of Learners
not everyone is great at sitting down
reading a bunch of text sometimes folks
really appreciate having a brief video
that walks them through the steps then
that can be a lot more productive
approach and as we pointed out
throughout this you can provide simple
documents and it works but having more
interactivity is certainly more
developer friendly we're not having to
go t developers and piece together the
bits from your content to then go to
some different tool try out the AP it's
always really convenient and timesaving
if I can just click a button it says try
it
works so just to touch again on
multimedia documentation I mention like
videos with simple walkthroughs as being
a really um userfriendly way to do it
another approach is pictures flowcharts
sometimes you've got in that cont
Concepts idea and documentation Big
Ideas that you have to convey and
sometimes just a few diagrams pictures
things like this can really help punch
through the point especially with you
know I think here it's called out that
it's useful for Less technical users I
think it's also just being tuned into
the fact again people learn differently
some people want to list to text some
people are more Visual and want kind of
a visual representation of what you're
describing um and again some people want
to be walked through with the videos
don't be afraid to try different ways to
connect with Learners as people are
learning how to use your
API um the other thing called out here
is you know sometimes we kind of stop at
this send a request get a result and
that's it but you really again want to
go beyond that mechanical interaction
into that step by-step guide can I walk
you through the process can I provide
some multi media in that process that
makes it easier to understand for
different kinds of lers or perhaps low
code developers non-technical users and
uh really make the most out of that
first
interaction interactive docs again just
to reiterate a really important to be
able to copy paste examples hit the try
button that sort of thing static
reference material can really leave you
lacking and get you pushed into using
other tools it's taking away a barrier
taking toil off of the end user and
ultimately all that adds up you know
having more media more ways to learn
more ways to interact with it all of
it's about creating this more positive
developer experience folks coming away
from it saying that was easy I want to
do that again
right I'm automated docs and we're going
to take a pause here in just a moment
and go look at this but using some sort
of spec format perhaps code annotations
things like this
it's a really good way to try to keep
things more programmatically in sync and
connect more Downstream tooling to a
shared definition and docs are just one
of the things that you can output from
that
spe and accessibility this is another
one that there's a lot of folks out
there and in this case who estimates
about 15% of the world um needs some
sort of specifically accessible content
so simple example of this actually is a
color blindness uh it's very common
thing especially among males so if
you're using let's say a color palette
or charts diagrams that use a certain
ranges of colors for colorblind folks
they can all look the same so that can
be very off-putting it could really kind
of suck the wife out of the multimedia
content that you're providing so it's
always good to think about a variety of
sort of accessibility concerns involved
here and it's not really that hard to go
use a variety of tools that are out
there that will go check your content
for you and give you an idea of where it
could cause problems for say visually uh
impaired
users um you know things like labels and
all texts on images can be really
helpful when you're using something like
a screen
reader and finally we're really going to
come down to a question here is
it's content up toate said it before out
ofate content in API docs is super
offputting and this is where having some
kind of process some kind of automation
some kind of connection between what you
built and what you're documenting can
really make a big
difference um things like screenshots
always seem like a great idea like this
going to make this so easy to understand
but you got to be really careful that
you don't end up with year two old
screenshots and you redesigned things
since then you've added functionality
that can be really disorienting if
suddenly the dots you're walking through
in the screenshots you're seeing don't
match
reality um and again this is about
embracing the fact that there's an
iterative life cycle to these things
this is not a oneandone
process the only thing you can count on
with apis is they're going to change
over time and you need to have a process
to make sure that uh you know not just
the reference material is getting
updated but also those guidance
tutorials task driven kinds of things
are also reviewed to make sure that with
the changes that we made do these things
still work another thing that happens
iteratively and creeps up on us is that
content gets bloated right making sure
that we're able to go through and really
streamline and simplify what we have
there take some intention as part of
that iterative process that let's look
at the big picture here as we've added
things over time has this gotten to
where it's just chore to grind through
all this content and figure out what to
do and another thing to watch out for
within that uh in that bloat is do you
have repetitive bits where you're
touching on the same Concepts in too
many places and it's just eating up
space and cluttering up the
experience and finally we didn't touch a
lot on expectations around search but
searching AAR large catalog of apis it
can be really difficult to find the
thing that you're looking for and some
of this does come back to how you're
documenting how you're describing things
and making sure that you're optimizing
for
relevance so we touched on tone and this
sort of thing and style is certainly a
factor here too and there's some
different templates folks use for style
things like that really this is coming
down to you know we can document one
andone API sure we can maybe even do it
hit Orly as a process but when we start
building lots of apis across a company
consistency is the name of the game
that's the really hard thing to achieve
is that you can do this repeatably in a
way that produces things that will feel
smell the same right so governance kind
of security measures you know you've got
to have some process you got to have
some pop into how this is going to work
and really focus on looking at that big
picture and making sure that is this a
great developer experience not just when
I look at one API but when I look at all
the different apis does it all feel like
one so that's what's going to take you
down the road of of really being able to
do API documentation at a bigger scale
and with that is the end of our course
thank you that wraps up the API
documentation best practices course hope
you enjoyed it if you'd like to earn a
badge and certificate for this course
please enroll at appc university.com
take the quizzes and we'll be happy to
issue your CT and while you're there be
sure to check out our other courses and
certifications we also host monthly
webinars with with API experts on
various topics and thanks again for
watching and hope to see you again soon